madame pour ce poli madame Lubin s'il
vous plaît
voilà
très bien
très bien donc mes chers collègues je
reprends donc la séance et nous
entendons ce matin Monsieur Pierre Mosco
ici en sa qualité de président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques pour nous
présenter
la vie du Haut conseil sur le projet de
loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 texte qui va nous
occuper dans les prochaines semaines
monsieur Moscovici accompagné Monsieur
Eric Dubois rapporteur général du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques ainsi que
des membres de l'équipe du secrétariat
permanent du
hcfp Axel Lacan Emmanuel jasmin et
Caroline Lebrun alors je devais
souhaiter la bienvenue à notre collègue
Sylvie vermilia qui rapporteur pour ravi
de la commission des finances mais elle
n'est pas là j'indique que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat la vidéo Conseil a été publiée
lundi et mis disposition sur Demeter et
monsieur le Président je vais vous
laisser la parole avant que nous
rapporteurs Elisabeth Doisneau
rapporteur général René Paul Savary qui
devrait arriver rapporteur pour les
retraites et si lui vermière rapporteur
pour avis puis les commissaires ne vous
adressent leurs questions monsieur le
Président je vous souhaite également
avant de démarrer une excellente année
2023 riche de travaux j'en suis certaine
si beaucoup madame la Présidente
et Messieurs les rapporteurs et
messieurs les sénateurs d'abord confus
de mon retard pour une bonne cause je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité ce matin
de votre commission en tant que donc
président du hcfp pour vous présenter
les principales conclusions de notre
avis relatif au projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale je vais dire une fois je ne
dirais pas
plrss pour 2023 je me permets tout
d'abord de vous présenter mes meilleurs
vœux pour cette année 2023 de vous dire
tout le plaisir que j'ai peut-être là
aujourd'hui devant vous et naturellement
la disponibilité que j'aurais y revenir
chaque fois que nos rapports nous
amèneront à ces échanges je commencerai
par un rappel des missions du Haut
Conseil qui a été en l'occurrence saisie
en application de l'article 61 de la loi
du premier août 2001 relative aux lois
de finance modifiées
le Conseil est appelé à donner trois
éclairages sur le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 qui vous est soumis
d'une part sur les prévisions
macroéconomiques sur lesquelles il
repose d'autre part sur le réaliste des
prévisions de recettes des dépenses
enfin le gouvernement a demandé où
acheter de se prononcer sur la cohérence
de son article liminaire au regard des
orientations plus réelles définies dans
le projet de loi de financement de
programmation des finances publiques se
fait partie de nos attributions mais
comme vous le savez il n'y a pas à ce
stade de loi de programmation des
finances publiques je vais y revenir au
regard dont des missions du Haut conseil
dont le rôle est justement
d'apprécier le réalisme des prévisions
macro-écume qui est des finances
publiques des textes financiers le hcfp
et c'est la première remarque que je
voudrais formuler à estimer que la
saisie du gouvernement était
particulièrement étroite en effet le
gouvernement n'a saisi le hcfp que sur
l'incidence de la réforme sur les fin
public pour la seule année 2023 au delà
il nous a été transmis que des
informations très partiel en termes
d'horizon jusqu'en 2026 en termes de
chant il s'agit des comptes des seuls
régimes de base et du sccfv et non de
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
et enfin d'explication sur le chiffrage
des différents dispositifs le Conseil
n'a donc pas été en mesure d'évaluer
l'incidence de moyen terme de la réforme
des retraites sur les finances publiques
et évidemment c'est tout de même un
sujet sinon le sujet décisif pour nous
ce prisme annuel est regrettable au
regard des conséquences d'une telle
réforme sur le moyen long terme et la
nécessité de l'expertise indépendante
qu'offre le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques et de son rôle en matière
d'examen des projets de loi de finances
et de financement Jean vient maintenant
cette remarque est en fait mais n'est
pas in importante et elle compte un peu
pour ensuite à nos deux principaux
messages relatifs au PLF RSS d'abord le
scénario macroéconomique du gouvernement
pour 2023 nous paraît toujours optimiste
même si les dernières informations
économiques disponibles montrent pour le
moment une résilience plus forte que
prévu de l'économie française ce dont
comme vous je me réjouis évidemment et
deuxième message la réforme des
retraites puisqu'on nous demande sur
2023 je vais répondre sur 2023 aura un
impact très faible sur les finances
publiques en 2023 le hcfp n'a pas pu en
revanche estimer sérieusement les
conséquences sur le moyen terme sur les
finances publiques faute de disposer des
informations suffisantes de la part du
gouvernement permettez-moi d'entrer de
brièvement dans le détail de ces deux
messages avant de répondre à vos
questions et je compléterai cette
présentation par quelques remarques tout
de même sur la situation générale des
finances publiques français je vais
commencer par l'analyse de la prévision
macroéconomique et de la situation à la
croquer le gouvernement
n'a pas modifié son scénario
macroïthmique par rapport aux lois de
finances et de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 qui date de
septembre dernier pour 2023 le
gouvernement continue de prévoir un
rythme de croissance du PIB de 1%
dans son avis sur le projet de loi
finance et le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 le Conseil avait alors estimé que
cette prévision était un peu élevée
qu'elle était fondée sur plusieurs
hypothèses fragiles et j'étais venu ici
pour essayer de vous démontrer en quoi
cette opinion a été fondée en outre les
informations conjonctureales récentes
laissent à penser très sérieusement que
la croissance est essoufflée fin 2022
pourquoi on le sait en raison de
l'impact de l'inflation et de la hausse
des taux d'intérêt sur la demande des
ménages et des entreprises
la prévision de 1% du gouvernement pour
2023 supposerait par conséquent une
accélération de l'activité au cours de
l'année
disons-le pour être tout à fait objectif
cette hypothèse ne peut pas être exclue
compte tenu des récents signaux
relativement positifs montrant une
certaine résilience de l'économie
française l'emploi demeure dynamique le
risque une rupture des
approvisionnements en électricité en gaz
par et désormais limité pour les
prochains mois plutôt clément les
tensions sur les prix l'énergie
s'atténue depuis l'été et le
ralentissement des commis allemandes et
plus généralement de la zone euro
apparaît moins prononcés qu'anticiper
l'automne notre partenaire allemand
devrait pouvoir éviter une récession en
néanmoins le Conseil continue de
considérer que le CN de croissance du
Grand est toujours optimiste
l'environnement international demeure
tout de même défavorable en 2023 alors
même que le durcissement des politiques
monétaires devraient se poursuivre
madame lacarde l'annoncer en réalité la
banquière notamment dans la zone euro et
sa contribuerait à freiner la demande au
cours des prochains trimestres
l'investissement pourrait notamment
partir de là hausse plus forte quantité
des taux d'intérêt dans la zone euro
dans un contexte d'incertitude élevé et
de fait même si nous avons des nouvelles
relativement bonnes plutôt moins
mauvaise que prévu la prévision de
croissance du gouvernement se situe au
dessus de l'ensemble des prévisions des
instituts de conjoncture français
internationaux ainsi que du consensus
des économistes qui en janvier
anticipe une croissance de l'économie
française de seulement 0,2% en 2023 la
Banque de France est à 0,3 vous le savez
le Conseil considère par conséquent que
la prévision de croissance qui est
annexée à ce projet reste élevé elle est
justifiée par le gouvernement par la
résilience française au troisième
trimestre 2022 et pas là qu'il
croissance sur 2023 elle sous-estime à
nos yeux cependant les facteurs de
freinage de l'activité qui sont
actuellement à l'oeuvre notamment le
niveau élevé de l'inflation et le
durcissement des politiques monétaires
le gouvernement prévoit également
toujours pour 2023 une hausse de
l'indice des prix de consommation de
4,2% moyenne annuel après une
progression de 5,2 en 2022
les prévisions d'inflation restent
dépendantes évolution des prix
énergétiques qu'il est aujourd'hui
difficile d'anticiper la fin de la
remise carburant au 31 décembre 2022 la
revalorisation de 15% en moyenne des
tarifs réglementés du gaz au 1er janvier
et l'électricité 1er février sont à
court terme des facteurs de hausse alors
que les baisses récentes les prix des
marchés du gaz du pétrole ont l'inverse
un effet clairement baissier
notre jugement est que le reflux
anticipé par le gouvernement de
l'inflation semble néanmoins rapides
cette prévision d'inflation pour 2023
elle est elle aussi plus faible que la
moyenne du consensus des économistes
plutôt la croissance des plus forts là
c'est plus faible on est toujours pas
dans le consensus le consensus est à 4,8
elle suppose un net infléchissement par
rapport aux tendances récentes or
l'indexation du SMIC et les hausses de
salaire déjà négociés ainsi que la
hausse des prix de production et
d'importation au prix des produits
alimentaires et manufacturés devraient
continuer à soutenir l'inflation en 2023
c'est ce que disent notamment vous le
savez
responsable de la grande distribution au
vu de ces éléments le Conseil considère
que la prévision d'inflation retenue
pour 2023 est un peu faible
le gouvernement a également maintenu sa
prévision d'une progression de ma
salariale des branches marchands non
agricoles 5% du 23 sa prévision de
croissance du salaire moyen nous paraît
faible en lien notamment avec la
sous-estimation des perspectives
d'inflation parce que sans qu'il y ait
d'indexation il y a tout de même un
rapport et si l'inflation était plus
élevée alors on peut anticiper des
hausses de salaire un peu plus élevées
également l'eau Conseil estime donc que
la prévision de ma salariale pour 2023
est un peu basse en résumé
sur ce premier message le Conseil estime
que la prévision de croissance pour 2023
est élevé qu'en revanche la prison
d'inflation est un peu basse tout comme
celle de la masse salariale
j'entre maintenant dans le détail des
constats du FCP concernant les finances
publiques sur la base de cette saisine
que je lui dis nous jugeons clairement
trop étroites le hcfp est chargé
d'évaluer le réalisme des recettes et
des dépenses du PDF RSS qui vous est
présenté veiller à la cohérence de ce
texte avec les orientations
pluriannuelles de finances publiques sur
ce dernier point il y a une évidence qui
est que la loi organique ne permet pas
au hcfp de se prononcer car le projet de
LPFP de loi de programmation de finance
publique présentée par le gouvernement
n'a pas à ce stade était adopté ceci me
donne l'occasion d'insister c'est à dire
lourdement parce que je crois que c'est
important sur un message que j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de présenter au Parlement
et que le HCF a repris dans son avis la
France ne peut pas se passer d'une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
c'est une obligation juridique qui est
organique qui est européenne mais c'est
surtout et avant tout un instrument de
pilotage indispensable des finances
publiques l'érosion progressive de la
position des finances publiques de la
France au sein de la zone euro les
investissements publiques massifs
auxquels notre pays fait face nécessite
de redresser nos comptes publics pour y
parvenir ce qui est tout à fait
atteignable sans recourir à l'austérité
comme le montre de nombreux exemples
européens l'effort doit évidemment être
piloté sur plusieurs années pour être
réaliste et pour préserver le potentiel
de croissance de l'économie c'est
pourquoi je le redis nous avons besoin
d'une telle programmation pluralienne et
je me permets puisque je suis devant la
route assemblée d'appeler toutes les
parties prenantes à faire en sorte que
la France se dote d'une telle loi de
programmation et ces deux que possible
je ne veux pas m'étendre là-dessus je ne
veux pas être alarmiste trop
c'est pas mon rôle en plus mais son
absence pose de nombreux problèmes
juridiques les problèmes politiques des
problèmes de pilotage donc il serait
vraiment dangereux de sous-estimer
l'importance l'absence de ce texte n'est
pas une anecdote c'est quelque chose
d'important et je dirais même d'assez
grave en réalité
je ne m'étends pas ça y est réaliste des
prévisions les dépenses et des recettes
présentées dans le PLFSS comme j'ai déjà
indiqué le gouvernement l'a transmis au
HCP que les impacts de la réforme des
retraites concernant les 2023 nos
constats sont les suivants les
conséquences du projet de réforme des
retraites sur les financiers en 2023
sont faibles avec un coût estimé par le
gouvernement
0,4 milliards d'euros une estimation que
nous jugeons réaliste ce cool la réforme
sur l'année 2023 résulte d'une part des
économies réalisées par le décalage de
trois mois du départ hors trade
d'environ 50 000 personnes en fin
d'année 2023 des recettes fiscales et de
cotisation sociale supplémentaires liées
à leur maintien dans l'emploi pendant
ces trois mois ça ce sont pour les
recettes et d'autre part des dépenses
supplémentaires entraînées par la
réforme ces dépenses sont notamment la
hausse du minimum contributif
dont les conditions précises restent
toutefois déterminées des mesures sur la
pénibilité et l'usure professionnelle
des mesures faveur des transitions
emplois retraite pour le dire simplement
sur 2023 les dépenses vont un peu plus
vite que les retours les recettes ou les
moindres des portes plus largement
s'agissant du solde prévu à 5 points de
piment en 2023 vous vous souvenez
peut-être que le CFP avait estimé en
septembre qu'il existait des risques que
le déficit pour 2023 soit plus dégradé
que prévu à ce jour ce risque il y a une
croissance plus faible et nous
maintenant que la croissance pourrait
être plus faible et contrebalancée par
la baisse récente des prix de gros du
gaz l'électricité qui elle si elle se
confirme pour être alléger le coût de
l'ensemble de dispositifs de soutien au
ménage et aux entreprises et donc il
n'est pas exclu qu'on soit à 5%
peut-être un peu moins peut-être un peu
plus en tout cas nous corrigeons un peu
notre appréciation ou vu de les morts
récents plutôt des bonnes nouvelles ce
qu'on appelle les win
s'agissant des impacts de plus long
terme sur les finances publiques qui
sont le cœur de la réforme des retraites
le HCP n'a pas eu d'information
suffisante pour lui permettre d'évaluer
l'incidence de la réforme à moyen terme
tout au plus avons-nous reçu l'annexe au
belf RSS portant sur la planète 2023
je le redis c'est tout à fait
regrettable c'est aussi très difficile à
comprendre alors que nos finances
publiques ont plus que jamais besoin
d'une gouvernance transparente et d'une
expertise indépendante qui n'est pas
qu'une expertise puisque nous sommes une
institution prévue par la loi organique
de 2012 toutefois même en l'absence de
ces informations nous faisons un
diagnostic qui je crois n'est pas
négligeable qui est que la réforme des
retraites dans ce pdf RSS ne devrait pas
améliorer la trajectoire de dette qui
avait présenté le gouvernement dans le
projet de FFP en septembre
elle ne témoigne en vérité d'aucune
ambition supplémentaire dans l'effort de
redressement des dépenses publiques
alors que son avis de septembre du HCP
la trajectoire présentée dans le projet
de loi de programmation était peu
ambitieuse en effet
la flexion visait la trajectoire de
dette était limitée et tardive la dette
amorçait sa décrit en 2027 alors même
que les y crottes prothèses de
croissance était quant à elle plutôt
optimiste cette trajectoire impliquée
d'ores et déjà une réforme de retraite
dans le projet du gouvernement dont le
Fcfp n'avait pas eu les détails les
données fournies au Conseil permettent
de constater que les déficits des
régimes de base de la sécurité sociale
du FSC sur la carte 2023-2026 sont
désormais un peu plus élevés un peu plus
élevé que dans la FLCS LFSS initiale
pour 2023 les dépenses de retraite
progressent dans le présent projet de
loi plus rapidement que prévu en
septembre une telle évolution et le
résultat de l'intégration de la réforme
des retraites dans la retraite ne mesure
qui n'était pas encore envisagées lors
de la présentation du projet de LPF qui
entraîne une légère dégradation des
comptes publics par rapport à ce qui
était prévu
donc voilà ça c'est quand même pas
d'inflexion de la trajectoire de dette
significative à attendre je voudrais
enfin terminer sur l'importance je ne
dis pas de là ça ce n'est pas mon sujet
mais d'une réforme des retraites il ne
revient pas au président du hcfp que je
suis pas davantage qu'au président de la
Cour des comptes que je suis également
dans des familles le contenu les
contours le calendrier les modalités
d'accompagnement de compensation tout ça
c'est la responsabilité du gouvernement
et du Parlement en lien avec les
partenaires sociaux
mais notre message là parle pour le coup
je suis dans mon rôle c'est dire qu'en
France le statu quo ne permettrait pas
de garantir la soutenabilité de nos
finances publiques il y a un problème de
comptabilité des finances publiques et
il y a un problème aussi de
soutenabilité du financement d'origine
de retraite notre rôle
c'est pas encore une fois de faire de la
politique c'est de vous présenter l'état
de nos finances publiques qui ont connu
une dégradation sur une longue période
qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui les marches de
manœuvre pour faire face aux chocs et
aux investissements publics dont le pays
a besoin je ne veux pas jouer les
Cassandre d'autres l'ont fait et on les
entend plus beaucoup mais nous avons
bien quand même à la fois une montagne
d'investissement à financer et un mur de
dette
si les deux se font face ça ne va pas il
faut donc organiser un moment donné un
système de base communicant et retrouver
des marges de manœuvre sur la dette pour
financer les investissements sans quoi
c'est pas comment on fait laissez-moi
seulement rappeler quelques éléments
factuels la France est entrée dans la
zone euro qui a ratio de dettes dans la
moyenne européenne équivalent celui de
l'Allemagne c'était en 2000
2001 58 points de PIB 20 ans plus tard
notre position relative c'est nettement
dégradée la dette de la Belgique qui
était très élevée augmentée d'un point
la dette de l'Allemagne augmentait de 10
points la dette de l'Italie donc
beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs estime qu'elle est beaucoup
trop élevée augmentée de 41 points la
dette de la France a augmenté de 55
points
un point 10 points 41 points 55 or cette
dette n'est plus gratuite nous sommes
sortis mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs clairement de l'ère des taux
d'intérêt négatifs le taux d'intérêt à
10 ans à retrouver son niveau
d'il y a 10 ans justement et alors que
la charge de la dette en comptabilité
nationale représentait 30 milliards en
2020 35 milliards en 2021 elle est
projetée déjà 44 milliards d'euros par
le gouvernement 2023 et nous savons que
le mouvement de hausse des taux n'est
pas arrêté que l'inflation n'est pas non
plus stoppée
or je l'ai déjà dit je te le dis depuis
des décennies en vérité il n'y a pas de
dépenses plus stérile et plus stupide
que la charge de la dette tout taureau
qu'on consacre à rembourser la dette est
un euro en moins pour n'importe quelle
politique publique utile
pourquoi est-ce un tel problème parce
que la France fait face je l'ai dit à
des besoins d'investissement public
majeurs aujourd'hui faut pas s'y tromper
c'est aujourd'hui et non demain que la
France doit rénover son système de santé
qu'elle doit rénover son système
scolaire qu'elle doit financer
ses dépenses militaires qu'elle doit
produire sur son territoire des biens
essentiels qu'elle doit investir dans la
recherche et développement pour se
maintenir de la compétition mondiale et
nous sommes très clairement en train de
décrocher sur toute une série de
secteurs par exemple en matière de santé
nous levonsir dans les infrastructures
pour nous adapter au changement
climatique et réduire
ces missions de CO2 donc je ne dis pas
qu'il n'y a pas de dépenses à faire il y
en a beaucoup mais si on n'a pas
d'argent pour le faire et qu'on est déjà
endetté et qu'on passe son temps à
rembourser la dette comment fait-on je
ne sais pas donc je le dis clairement je
ne crois pas que l'État et la dynamique
de nos finances publiques permettent de
répondre à ces défis
réformer les retraites fait partie de
l'effort collectif à entreprendre mais
je termine par là madame et messieurs
les sénateurs ça ne suffira pas la
France a aussi la capacité la nécessité
d'améliorer ses comptes publics dans
tous les secteurs des politiques
publiques en recherchant j'insiste sur
ce mot la qualité de la dépense publique
ce qui n'est pas chose facile et
pourtant de nombreux pays ont procédé
avec succès dans cet exercice c'est ce
qu'on appelle les revues de dépenses
j'ai vu que le ministre des Finances
l'avaient annoncé il a raison c'est
nécessaire il a invité à des acides de
finances publiques la Cour des comptes
et le Conseil y participeront mais si on
fait de telles revues dépenses il faut
lui donner une gouvernance une raison
d'être un calendrier une méthode des
objectifs clairs
ça doit pas être une grand-messe ça doit
être un exercice continue et profond les
défis du temps j'en finis par là nous
appel à la fois l'ambition nécessaire
mais aussi au sérieux et c'est vrai en
matière budgétaire
souvenons-nous que il y a peu de moi un
de nos voisins qui certes n'est pas dans
la zone euro et c'était plus compliqué
pour lui la Grande-Bretagne
a connu des tensions sur sa dette
inattendues et ça nous montre qu'il faut
agir aujourd'hui et non demain sinon on
s'expose au risque qu'un beau jour
plutôt un mauvais jour sous pression
arrive un accident et c'est le moment il
faut couper drastiquement dans les
dépenses ou relever brutalement les
impôts et je crois qu'il ne faut faire
ni l'un ni l'autre rien de tout cela ne
serait dans l'intérêt de notre pays
voilà pourquoi il faut anticiper traiter
maintenant la question de la dette et
améliorer la qualité de notre dépense
publique une réforme des retraites
encore une fois à vous de la déterminer
on fait partie voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs les principales
observations du Haut conseil que je
souhaitais partager avec vous ce matin
merci de votre attention je me tiens à
votre disposition avec en effet l'équipe
qui m'entoure
qui fait toujours un travail remarquable
en très peu de temps sous grosse
pression pour répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le Président voilà nous
démarrons bien l'année
n'est pas bien cette journée avec ce
tableau réaliste du de nos finances
publiques je vais passer la parole à
rapporteur généralisabetho
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président pour vos propos
qui sont très claires et qui nous
amènent effectivement au pied du mur
comme vous le dites je voudrais vous
souhaiter une très très bonne année bien
sûr ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de votre
équipe et vous remercier des travaux que
vous menez les uns les autres pour nous
éclairer sur ce chemin difficile de
choix politiques sérieux et
en totale
avec les éléments dont nous disposons
les uns les autres et qui parfois sont
pas suffisants comme vous avez pu le
dire
c'est vrai que nous aurions souhaité les
uns les autres à voir ce collectif
social déjà les années précédentes là où
on a eu des décisions importantes à
prendre sur des dépenses
énormes or nous ne les avons pas eu ni
en 2020 ni en 2021 ni en 2022 et là il
se trouve qu'aujourd'hui on veut
retrouve donc c'est un quelque sorte un
certain paradoxe
de travailler sur un PLF RSS c'est vrai
aussi je le dirais qu'une seule fois
parce que c'est vraiment la barbare
qu'on pourra comment
admettre les uns et les autres alors je
vais me limiter en fait à trois
questions parce que je pense qu'il faut
laisser aussi à nos collègues le loisirs
de s'exprimer et j'ai à mes côtés en
plus René Paul Savary qui est notre
référent sur les retraites et qui sera
aussi
comment
aller sur les questions les plus
essentielles sur un plan très
conjoncturel le Haut Conseil considère
que la prévision de croissance du
gouvernement reste élevé c'est ce que
vous avez dit
qu'elle est en tout cas optimiste c'est
le thème que vous avez employé je relève
que que le mouvement social lié à la
réforme des retraites elle-même ne
figure pas parmi les facteurs de risque
or nous le voyons bien chaque jour les
annonces sont de plus en plus
importantes de grève par ci de grève par
là de blocage par ciblocage par là et ça
ça peut plomber l'économie et il n'en
est il en question dans votre dans vos
propos est-ce que vous pensez que vous
considérez que d'éventuelles grève et
blocage ne devrait pas avoir que peu
d'impact d'un point de vue économique
c'est la question ma deuxième question à
plus long terme comment le Haut Conseil
apprécit-il le caractère réaliste de la
trajectoire financière pluriannuelle de
la branche vieillesse au vu de la
réforme proposée avec les limites que
vous avez indiquées en complément y
a-t-il selon vous une marge pour l'ajout
de mesure généreuses que nous pourrions
les uns et les autres imaginer
comment on avançant dans cet examen de
ce projet de loi donc de mesures
généreuses ou d'athénomation de la
réforme en cours de navette pour
parvenir à un objectif bien sûr
d'équilibre
la troisième la dernière question enfin
à la frontière de vos compétences de
Premier président de la Cour des comptes
considérez-vous opportun de jouer sur le
levier de la solidarité inter-branche en
particulier avec la branche ATMP et je
parle sous le torité de notre collègue
qui s'occupe de la branche TMP Pascal
grunis est-ce que vous pensez que donc
c'est c'est nécessaire et et intelligent
pour boucler le financement de la
réforme ou cela constitue-t-il une forme
de dévoiement en tout cas voilà pour mes
questions je dirais simplement que comme
vous monsieur le Président je suis assez
comment
inquiète c'est anxieuse sur la réaction
des Français par rapport à cette réforme
parce que je crois qu'on laisse trop de
dettes aux générations qui viennent vous
avez parlé d'une montagne
d'investissement mais vous avez énuméré
toutes les questions tous les sujets
sérieux que nous devrions ré aborder ou
aborder avec en conscience avec beaucoup
beaucoup de d'attention ce sont donc des
dépenses et puis il y a cette dette bref
on laisse les factures à nos enfants et
c'est terrible merci
on va prendre peut-être les questions de
René Paul ça varie et ensuite on sera
monsieur
à l'intérêt de ce rapport simplement
on voit que la trajectoire du
gouvernement est fondée sur un scénario
1% de productivité 4 et demi de chômage
et que c'est comme ça qu'on estime le
déficit en 2070 aux alentours 13-14
milliards mais si on a un taux de
chômage à 7% rien que là on tombe à 19
milliards donc pensez-vous que cette
trajectoire est bonne et optimiste et un
deuxième point la réforme qui est une
réforme pour équilibrer les comptes nous
semble-t-il en 2070 du régime de
retraite montre que même si c'est
équilibré il y aura encore des déficits
importants même pour le régime général
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
inquiétant et quand on voit l'évolution
du système par répartition le fait de
prendre des mesures d'équilibre
régulièrement est-ce que quand il y a un
taux de natalité qui baisse de plus en
plus un nombre de cotisants qui diminue
par rapport au nombre de retraités un
délai de une durée de retraite qui est
de plus en plus longue pensez-vous que
le système par répartition peut un jour
être remis en cause et on remarques de
rapporteur général à savoir l'impact des
grèves sur l'économie qui n'a pas
semble-t-il été pris en compte il y a
peut-être un autre élément qui a pas été
pris en compte pour les
l'impact en 2023 que j'ai découvert
suite à une discussion avec l'argile
Carco c'est qu'il y a un nombre de
liquidation des retraites notamment de
ceux qui étaient en surcotte qui vont
pouvoir partir et qui en fait compte
tenu des incertitudes de la réforme
depuis qu'elle est annoncée depuis deux
trois mois liquide leur retraite alors
qu'il ne l'avait pas
forcément envisagé ce qui fait qu'ils
ont un nombre de dossiers de liquidation
beaucoup beaucoup plus important que
ceux qui connaissent habituellement ce
qui voudrait dire que derrière il y a
déjà un impact éventuellement financier
par des gens qui prennent leur retraite
par anticipation par rapport à leur
prévision qui risque d'annuler un peu
les effets de la réforme des 2023 qu'en
pensez-vous merci
voilà monsieur le président
je vais
je m'en excuse décevoir le rapporteur
général monsieur le sénateur parce que
je suis ici en ma qualité de président
du hcfp et non pas comme premier
président de la Cour des comptes je vais
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
notamment à chapitre introductif sur les
finances publiques dans le prochain
rapport public annuel que je rendrai au
président de la République et au
Parlement le 15 mars prochain mais
je ne serai pas fâché d'entrer dans ce
débat mais en tant que président du HCP
j'ai une compétence limitée vous me
pardonnerez de m'y tenir de ne pas
spéculer trop d'autant que je le redis
nous avons en fait très peu d'éléments
et c'est sur quoi je voulais assister
vous m'interrogez au fond sur les
scénarios d'une part et d'abord sur
l'impact à moyen terme de la réforme des
retraites c'est vrai que mais là je m'en
tiens des informations rendues publiques
les dispositions du plfs conduit à
réduire le défi de 13 milliards en 2030
projette pas au-delà le déficit public
baisserait donc d'environ 0,4 points de
PIB toutes choses égales par ailleurs à
cet horizon 2030 donc bien au-delà de
l'horizon de la ltfp qui n'existe pas
mais comme nous l'avons indiqué les
informations transmises au Conseil ne
lui ont pas permis d'évaluer l'incidence
de moyen terme de la réforme des
retraites sur les finances publiques
notamment son effet sur les dépenses le
gouvernement n'a par exemple pas fourni
d'éléments sur le nombre de personnes
qui devront décaler leur départ ni sur
le montant de retraite alors à forceurie
pas sur ceux qui ont ici ou sur les
comportements peuvent avoir ici là on
outre le chiffrage vraiment de prendre
en compte que les effets mécaniques des
mesures annoncées ne tient pas compte tu
as des pensées
d'invalidité d'indemnités journalières
d’inviter le chômage
qui devrait découler du maintien sur le
marché de travail de salariés à
l'inverse il ne tient pas compte du
surcroît de recette du à la hausse des
taux d'emploi aux âges élevés ou je
crois de production résultant en toute
état de cause je m'en tiens à ça le gain
dégagé par la forme des retraites ne
suffira pas lui seul je l'ai dit à
restaurer les marges manœuvre
suffisantes ça c'est absolument clair
vous m'avez interrogé madame le
rapporteur général
sur sur les les grèves
d'abord c'est pas tout à fait notre
métier que de mesurer cet impact disons
que
il y a toujours un impact à court terme
mais en général peu élevé sur les
finances publiques par exemple les coûts
du conflit 1995 qui n'a pas été dans mon
souvenir le plus léger mettez le plus
dur ont été d'environ un point de pipe
donc relativement négligeable en général
c'est un effet de court terme qui est
rattrapé ensuite et notons que depuis
1995 les différents effets de
législation et autres font que ces cours
ont tendance à se limiter et que les
mouvements sociaux s'organisent
autrement donc pour être hors de ma zone
de confort mais quand même m'engager un
peu je pense qu'il fait sont très
limités s'il y en a c'est pas ça qu'il
faut craindre économiquement je pense
pour le reste je lui dis je n'ai pas de
suffisamment d'informations pour vous
répondre madame rapporteur de manière
pertinente sur les marges de manoeuvre
dont disposons puisque n'ayant pas
d'impact à moyen terme je peux pas vous
dire à fortiori ce que sont les marges
disponibles désolé d'être aussi
lacunaire mais
je le suis à mesure des informations
dont je dispose et encore une fois je ne
voudrais pas sortir de mon rôle ici de
prison du hcfp et m'engager comme ça sur
des débats très importants en matière de
protection sociale sur lesquels cour et
compétente mais elle est passée dire en
l'occurrence
merci alors nous allons prendre quatre
commissaires pour une première salle de
question et ensuite nous aurons trois
autres commissaires Raymond de pensées
Bernard Chemillé qui était pour ce
polymonique Lubin vraiment de penser
oui merci
monsieur le Président écoutez
nous regrettons avec vous le caractère
incomplet des éléments qui vous ont été
transmis par le gouvernement et qui ne
vous permet pas donc d'évaluer l'impact
à moyen terme de la réforme donc nous
naviguons à vue par rapport à ce rapport
mais la première chose que je voulais
dire c'est c'est vrai que vous êtes tenu
à l'impact sur la sur le système des
retraites c'est normal mais vous n'avez
pas élargi l'étude des impacts de la
réforme en dehors du système des
retraites en mesure notamment les
dépenses supplémentaires sur le chômage
ou sur le RSA qui vont être induite
puisque le corps indique le report de 62
à 64 implique une hausse des dépenses en
termes de prestation sociale hors
retraite de 3,9 milliards alors c'était
peut-être pas votre commande mais c'est
vrai que c'est un volant qui est un peu
un point aveugle de votre rapport et ma
question est celle là vous estimez à
50000 personnes sur un quadrimestre donc
il faudrait presque multiplier par trois
si on veut voir des générations
suivantes mais 50 000 personnes sur la
quadrimés de cette année qui seront donc
décalés dans leur dans leur prise enfin
dans le départ 900 ce qui a été dit
c'est qu'effectivement les personnes qui
n'ont plus de surcote vont peut-être
liquider avant puisque quand même le
mécanisme des surcotes étaient crasés
par cette réforme donc parmi ces 50000
personnes comme vous avez calculés les
recettes induites de par leur cotisation
ou les économies de par le fait qu'ils
moi j'aimerais savoir et vous devez le
savoir comment vous pouviez pas calculer
combien était en emploi combien étaient
déjà en chemin enfin tu es en emploi
combien était en chômage et combien
était en ligne inactivité ce qu'on
appelle les né en emploi ni en retraite
je vous remercie
Bernard jaumier merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
pour votre exposé
vous avez
longuement insisté sur la nécessité
d'avoir une loi de programmation des
finances publiques alors pour discuter
un peu de ce point vous interrogez on
est quand même une loi politique la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
donc pardon de vous entraîner sur ce
terrain là mais un des un des débats que
nous avons tenté d'avoir avec le
gouvernement porte sur la structure de
la dépense publique vous avez relevé que
elle a augmenté qu'il y a des
investissements lourds auxquels procéder
or quand on analyse cette dépense
publique sur les dernières décennies le
financement de notre service public la
part relative du financement de nos
services publics c'est réduite et nous
avons des services publics y compris des
fonctions régaliennes de l'État comme la
justice qui sont en grande difficulté
nos infrastructures ferroviaires ne sont
pas particulièrement en bon état etc
et nous avons augmenté par contre très
fortement
les transferts vers les entreprises et
vers les ménages et nous avons tenté de
poser ce débat lors de la dernière loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
parce que le Conseil d'analysé
économique lui-même pointe le fait que
certains transferts vers les entreprises
ont une utilité démontrée sur l'emploi
mais d'autres le Conseil les qualifie
d'inefficace et pourtant il n'est pas
possible de mener ce débat le
gouvernement ferme la porte à toute
évolution en la matière alors il est
compliqué pour des assemblées qui sont
des assemblées politiques
d'approuver y compris par des compromis
une loi de programmation des finances
publiques s'il n'est pas possible de
discuter de la structure de la dépense
publique vous en conviendrez et la
deuxième question que je voulais vous
poser et au regard des des dépenses en
termes de compétitivité qui ont été
importantes dans notre pays qui
notamment consiste pour une partie aux
exonérations en direction des
entreprises on constate que sur deux
décennies le commerce extérieur ne se
porte pas mieux que la
réindustrialisation du pays
on va dire est très faible voilà il y a
eu un légère un léger mouvement on va
dire depuis deux ans mais c'est un
phénomène qui reste est faible et que
par ailleurs cette positive là a eu à
des impacts climatiques qui maintenant
sont relevés et je ne parle pas des
impacts sur la souveraineté de notre
pays au fond est-ce qu'il faut
poursuivre dans cette direction
merci Katia pour soupe
je vous remercie bien tout d'abord
vous disiez dans votre propos que les
finances publiques avaient besoin de
transparence
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
évidemment mais je pense que nous en
sommes malheureusement très loin alors
moi j'ai deux questions
ne pensez vous pas que les 2 milliards
d'euros d'exonération donc de
cotisations retraite aux employeurs ne
devraient pas être minima compensés par
l'État chaque année ce qui n'est quand
même pas le cas et puis ma deuxième
question c'est sur la CNRACL la
revalorisation des pensions minimales à
1200 euros brut pas net mais brut va
impacter les collectivités qui ont
beaucoup d'agents il faut le dire en
catégorie C et vont devoir payer 800
millions d'euros
supplémentaires en raison donc de la
réforme du gouvernement alors que ces
collectivités pour l'instant ne seront
pas impactés ne seront pas compensés à
leur auprès sur l'augmentation du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires donc
il ne faudrait-il pas donc un mécanisme
par rapport donc à la revalorisation des
pensions minimales de compensation par
l'État ou collectivité territoriales je
vous remercie Monique Lebas
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président cette réforme nous a été
présentée comme la mère des réformes et
vous venez de confirmer qu'en fait au vu
en tout cas des éléments
insuffisants nous l'avons bien compris
qui sont votre possession
que cette réforme ne pourra avoir qu'un
effet finalement minime et en tout cas
qu'elle sera loin d'être suffisante pour
faire baisser à elle seule le niveau de
la dette vous insistez sur la nécessité
de maîtriser la dette ce dont personne
ne dis ce qu'on vient je pense mais
lorsqu'on parle de faire baisser la
dette on s'est immédiatement les baisses
de dépenses et vous précisez qu'il ne
serait ni opportun d'abaisser
drastiquement les dépenses ni opportun
donc monter les impôts bon donc les
marges de manoeuvre ressemblent quand
même assez réduite néanmoins compte tenu
du tableau que vous venez de nous
dresser
pensez-vous que les les baisses d'impôts
qui ont été considérables sur ces cinq
dernières années et nous avons encore eu
sur le budget 2023 la fin de la de la
CVAE donc tous impôts confondus
pensez-vous que cette trajectoire puisse
durer éternellement
c'est le président première série de
questions
[Musique]
je redis que mes réponses notamment sur
la structure des recettes des dépenses
sociales les compensations sont
forcément limitées elles sont limitées
par les compétences qui sont les miennes
aujourd'hui en tant que président de la
CSP et encore plus limité par la nature
vraiment étroite des informations dont
je dispose et la saisie néanmoins ce que
je peux dire c'est plusieurs choses
d'abord sur sur l'impact financier pour
2023 juridique il y avait un coup de 400
millions d'euros je redis parce que au
milieu de des différents messages que je
passais il y en a qui n'était pas passé
c'est que nous estimons que c'est
réaliste ce coup de 400 millions d'euros
conduit d'informations dont nous
disposons alors après vous m'interrogez
sur le chômage supplémentaire parmi les
personnes pas la retraite à 60 61 ans
France stratégie à réaliser une
évaluation qui date un peu
la moitié est en activité
10% sur le chômage et un tiers sont en
gros inactives quant à l'estimation de
50000 personnes qui décalent leur départ
à la retraite en 2023 ce sont les
personnes qui sont réforme des retraites
seraient parti dès lors 62 ans à partir
du 1er octobre novembre décembre sans la
réforme qui devront décalerait pas et
environ 200 000 personnes par an en
effet
quatre trimestres qui partent en
retraite dès l'âge légalatins sur un peu
plus de 700 000 départs par an les
personnes qui comptaient partir à la
retraite dès leur 62 ans à partir du 1er
octobre novembre décembre et qui devront
représenter leur départ représente un
quart des personnes qui auraient pris la
retraite des 62 ans qui est donc environ
50000 personnes en effet là encore nous
estimons que cette mesure est réaliste
donc si vous vous la projetez pour la
suite ça devrait être de l'ordre de 200
000 et encore une fois nous n'avons pas
nous d'informations
que nous avons été amenés à faire sur
les lois de programmation des finances
publiques
tout ça rend les choses quand même un
peu gazeuses et nous ne sommes pas à
l'abri d'avoir à ce moment-là un
processus de finance publique qui est
d'abord mal éclairé peut transparent et
de plus discontinue car nous pouvons pas
baser par exemple une boîte de règlement
sur des informations fiables
c'est un vrai risque juridique c'est un
vrai risque juridique c'est pas à moi de
l'évaluer mais il existe chacun le sait
et le sous-estimé en remettant ça comme
la poussière sur le tapis n'est pas
prudent deuxièmement dans une autre vie
pas si ancienne j'étais de l'autre côté
de la frontière belge à Bruxelles où
j'étais commissaire et en charge
justement ces problèmes de finances
publiques
coup de chance en ce moment il y a pas
de règles de finances publiques
européennes qui souhaitent
opérationnelles coup de chance
conjoncturelle car à un moment donné on
va rétablir des règles et il le faut par
ailleurs car son règle n'a pas de
boussole et pas d'encre
la Commission européenne a besoin
également d'une programmation de finance
publique pour fonder ses décisions
ces opinions
et donc à un moment donné elle pourrait
estimer que c'est un élément manquant
fondamental y compris pour la mise en
oeuvre d'un certain nombre de
financement européen voilà la raison
pour laquelle sur un plan formel mais il
est important je me permets d'insister
sur le fait que l'absence de loi de
programmation de finance publique n'est
pas une bricole n'est pas une anecdote
que c'est un problème substantiel et
assez préoccupant après monsieur le
sénateur vous m'a poussé un peu plus
loin je vais quand même vous répondre
parce que en effet nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion d'en débattre sur ces sujets
au sein du Haut Conseil et comme à la
Cour des comptes
nous avons quand même un vrai paradoxe
français c'est que nous avons
le plus haut niveau de dépense publique
de l'Union européenne avec le Danemark
quelques 58% du PIB et pourtant nous
observons une perception au moins mais
aussi parfois une réalité de dégradation
de la qualité de certains services
publics je rappelle que la Cour des
comptes avant l'élection présidentielle
en décembre 2021 avait sorti toute une
série de notre structurels qui
démontrait un certain nombre de
défaillances mais si je veux en prendre
deux exemples prenons l'exemple de la
politique du logement en France qui est
deux fois plus coûteuse que la moyenne
de l'Union européenne juste deux fois
plus coûteuse et qui n'est pas jugé
comme plus performante y compris par
rapport à son objectif central qu'il
délivrait des logements sociaux
je ne plaide pas du tout pour couper par
deux les dépenses du logement mais on
voit bien qu'il y a un problème vous
l'avez dit vous-même monsieur le
sénateur d'efficacité deuxièmement en
matière d'éducation un système éducatif
puissant massif coûteux dont les
performances se dégradent ça c'est les
mesures bizarres de l'OCDE etc
ça prouve bien qu'il y a des problèmes
d'efficacité de la dépense publique
alors après il faut les chercher vous
avez parlé des mesures de transfert
France stratégie estime que les mesures
de transfert vers les entreprises ont
plutôt un effet positif sur la
compétitivité mais je veux pas répondre
à la place de ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est que la nécessité
absolue c'est bel et bien celle de ses
revues de dépenses publiques il faut
soulever le capot la dépense publique et
des politiques publiques voir ce qui
marche ce qui ne marche pas retenir ce
qui marche le développer le muscler
investir et être capable aussi
d'économiser ou de maîtriser la dépense
sur ce qui ne fonctionne pas j'ai pas
toutes les réponses la Cour des comptes
participera ces exercices mais c'est
indispensable sinon on va entrer dans un
paradoxe vraiment très coûteux un moment
donné où nos compatriotes à la fois se
plaignent d'un excès de dépense financé
par des prélèvements
fiscal je ne sais pas si qui c'était et
de l'autre côté il peut y avoir un effet
où les services publics eux-mêmes sont
perçus comme peu fonctionnel et chacun
peut en faire l'expérience ça ne marche
pas et pour attraper ça il faut
absolument améliorer la qualité de votre
dépense publique voilà la finalité de
l'exercice et quel que soit après tout
les préférences politiques dans cette
salle il y en a qui sont différentes
c'est normal c'est le démocratie chacun
doit y participer personne ne peut
satisfaire au niveau de dépenses et tu
ne faible quantité de prestation ça me
paraît quand même du bon sens si le
surcroît on est face à un endettement
massif et qu'on ne peut pas financer ni
l'existant ni l'avenir là on se trouve
quand même dans un nœud gardien qui est
quand même tout à fait singulier enfin
sur sur les baisses d'impôts puisque la
question m'a été posée je ici redire un
message que j'ai exprimé à plusieurs
reprises en septembre
que ce soit en tant que président de la
Cour des comptes ou en tant que
président du hcfp
si on doit et c'est le point de vue de
la Cour des comptes comme du HFP
maîtriser nos finances publiques donc
réduire nos déficits et notre dette il y
a finalement que trois voix
soit on fait de la croissance
il faut le faire il faut muscler notre
croissance potentielle comme on dit mais
que personne ici ne nourrissent une
illusion nous ne sommes pas à l'aube de
Trente Glorieuses nous aurons dans les
années qui viennent des taux de
croissance qui seront limités limitées
donc n'ayons pas l'illusion de la
croissance magique la croissance vaille
pour voir non faisons le plus de
croissance possible et de toute façon ce
ne sont pas des années extraordinaires
qui nous attendent deuxième solution
on peut et il faut maîtriser les
dépenses
et la troisième c'est d'agir sur les
recettes or il y a un plafond plus
consentement à l'impôt que nous
constatons tous chez nos concitoyens
alors qu'ils appartiennent au places
populaires couches moyennes
bon donc à un moment donné n'ayons pas
non plus l'illusion que les impôts vont
le faire
le message que délivrer la cour il était
très clair il a d'ailleurs été entendu
c'est que nous n'avons pas en l'état
dans le circonstances de croissance
faible
avec une dépense qui continue
d'augmenter nous n'avons pas les marges
de manœuvre pour faire des baisses
d'impôts sèches c'est la non compensé
soit par d'autres hausse d'impôts
soit par une maîtrise des dépenses a du
concurrence et donc nous l'avons dit ce
qui a été entendu par le gouvernement
qui en effet décidé d'étaler un certain
nombre de décision parce que sinon des
baisses impôts sèche n'auraient eu qu'un
seul effet qui aurait été creusé le
déficit ce que nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre puisque nous avons déjà des
objectifs de finances publiques qui sont
beaucoup trop peu ambitieux voilà je ne
fais pas plus loin dans la démonstration
mais ça souligne encore une fois
l'impératif absolu ça c'est vraiment un
message que je voudrais faire partager
d'une d'un travail maintenant en
profondeur sur la qualité de la dépense
publique pour réduire cet écart entre la
perception d'une dégradation des
services publics des dépenses publiques
qui restent très élevées des
prélèvements obligatoires qui eux aussi
sont très pesants pour nos concitoyens
tant qu'on ne sort pas de ça alors on
est quand même dans une aire
d'insatisfaction qu'on peut comprendre
mais je sors de mon rôle
donc je m'arrête
il est mouillé
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci pour vos propos
j'ai un peu le sentiment vous écoutant
de de je me revois il y a quelques mois
lorsque nous avons déjà une analyse de
la situation du bénéfice et vous propose
des très proches avec beaucoup
d'interrogations sur
la pertinence des taux de croissance
affichées le volume des dépenses on
retrouve finalement le même discours on
regarde une situation qui semble à peu
près équivalente même si il y a des
éléments nouveaux de réforme qui sont
proposés j'ai on a bien entendu aussi
que vous êtes dans un rôle qui reste
limité aujourd'hui puisque vous êtes sur
l'analyse finalement de l'évolution de
2023 alors c'est vrai que pour nous ça
peut une frustration parce que moi quand
je suis ce matin j'étais heureux de vous
rencontrer de vous entendre et de
bénéficier de votre savoir-faire autour
de tout ça
alors ma question ma question est la
suivante puisque on a bien compris que
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez que nous
évoquer des grands principes généraux et
en tous les cas on a noté on a noté très
fortement avec un crayon les enjeux sur
la tout ce qui est programmation et
d'ailleurs pour les finances publiques
comme dans d'autres politiques publiques
d'une façon générale moi j'ai une
question de réaction à votre
démonstration vous évoquez les
différents leviers la croissance les
économies les sons de la dette moi j'ai
une question très simple parce que vous
croyez d'une façon générale en lien avec
ces réformes des retraites que la notion
de l'augmentation du temps de travail
que ça soit par l'augmentation de la
durée de travail dans la vie ou par
rapport l'augmentation générale stricte
du temps de travail regard à la fois de
votre positionnement de votre expérience
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible un levier essentiel qui
pourrait peut-être venir contrecarrer le
scénario extrêmement étroit que vous
évoquez comme étant une possible
démarche manœuvre voilà voilà ma
question
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président vous avez
précisé à juste titre que vous deviez
calibrer vos propos compte tenu de la
compétence qui est la vôtre ici
il n'empêche
la nature même de votre exposé nous
invite à nous poser les bonnes questions
et le fait d'entendre que
on a besoin d'éclairage de transparence
sur les dépenses publiques nous nous
alerte et vous n'en avez convaincu enfin
moi vous m'avez convaincu était-ce
nécessaire que l'absence de loi de
programmation des finances publiques est
un risque juridique
mais je dirais que c'est aussi un risque
politique et c'est même un risque
démocratique
parce que on a un au niveau de
prélèvement comme vous l'avez dit au
niveau dette
mais si c'était pour des investissements
de long terme et si c'était pour avoir
des services publics qui soient perçus
comme fonctionnant parfaitement et
rendant les services qui doivent rendre
je pense que nos concitoyens pourraient
l'accepter mais il se posent une
question terrible à tous les niveaux un
classe populaire classe moyenne personne
plus favorisées c'est où va l'argent
cette question là on l'entende de plus
en plus alors elle paraît basique simple
mais je pense que elle nous elle nous
interpelle cette question qui sommes
responsables et donc
vous avez évoqué le niveau de dette qui
a progressé de 55 points pour la France
de de 41 points pour l'Italie mais
est-ce que
cette loi de programmation pourrait
aussi nous permettre d'avoir des
éléments comparatifs sur la structure de
nos dépenses les transferts les
investissements le fonctionnement des
services publics et pouvoir avoir des
des niveaux de comparaison avec les
autres pays européens comme vous en avez
nous en avez donné pour le niveau
d'endettement parce que moi même comme
rapporteur de la branche famille je suis
toujours étonné du manque de de
benchmark on peut avoir sur des
politiques essentielles comme la
politique familiale au moment où la
natalité est en berne par rapport à des
niveaux de comparaison sur d'autres
politique qui sont menées par les pays
européens je vous remercie
Daniel
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président pour pour vos
propos
vous nous avez rappelé effectivement que
la dette de la France et de l'Allemagne
par rapport au PIB et la même en 2000
et qu'elle a augmenté de petites
conviennent de le dire Olivier de 55
points et l'Italie 40 la Belgique ça
veut dire que il y a eu des efforts plus
importants dans d'autres pays que nous
pour maîtriser la dette et en fait vous
l'avez dit la charge de la dette était
de 30 milliards en 2020 et va passer
bientôt à 40 ou 50 milliards c'est à
dire qu'en fait plus haut plus on
empruntait finalement on gagnait en
empruntant mais on a changé complètement
tout cela avec les difficultés la guerre
en Ukraine et l'inflation donc si vous
voulez vous nous avez également dit que
bien on avait des dépenses générales en
France plus importante pour au niveau
public et pense publique plus importante
et que fallait trouver les moyens de
maîtriser les dépenses d'être plus
efficace effectivement dans les dans les
services publics mais
on voit que le Président de la
République nous dit qu'il faut augmenter
a juste titre sûrement le budget des
armées il faut augmenter aussi dans la
santé on voit bien et dans dans
l'éducation enfin voilà alors si vous
voulez
qu'est-ce qui y reste et à maîtriser les
dépenses à mieux orienter les dépenses
mais pour avoir
pour maîtriser la dette ne faut-il pas
avoir plus de recettes c'est à dire que
faire on a faire un petit peu ce qu'a
fait l'Allemagne en 2000 c'est-à-dire
réindustrialiser le pays pour avoir plus
de retraite nous pour avoir plus de
recettes vous nous avez dit que les
retraites bon vont pas apporter
énormément mais c'est quand même pas mal
d'équilibrer un budget puisque le budget
des retraites fait partie aussi de la
sécurité sociale donc ne faut-il pas
avoir une loi de programmation pour la
réindustrie réalisation du pays pour que
on est plus de plus de recettes pour
d'abord équilibrer notre budget ne plus
faire d'elle et après progressivement
essayer de rembourser des dettes pour ne
pas aller complètement dans le mur
pour terminer Florence assarade et
Frédéric pyssa Florence merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président moi
j'ai une question de détails à vous
poser un exemple comme quoi l'état
ferait mieux de faire de la pédagogie
plutôt que de la démagogie je m'explique
les le cumul emploi retraite des des
médecins étaient limité par le fait que
les médecins devaient continuer à payer
leur cotisations retraite on a décidé
enfin d'ensemble que finalement ces
cotisations retraite ils allaient en
être exonérés or c'est finalement la
caisse de retraite des médecins qui paye
la différence résultat elle n'augmente
pas les les pensions de ces
médecins finalement l'opération est
nulle pour l'État en coût mais par
contre au point du confiance dans le
système et adhésion des des
médecins dans l'exemple donné à ses
possibilités de de réforme de retraite
catastrophique est-ce que ça va être
pareil à tout niveau
et pour terminer Frédéric oui merci
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président une question un peu rapide moi
j'entends les enjeux la nécessité et je
pense que vous vous avez déjà un public
un peu convaincu dans la salle d'une
noix de programmation des défenses
publiques j'entends que pour qu'elle
soit acceptable elle doit s'inscrire
dans le temps et qu'elle doit
nécessairement faire preuve d'une
analyse à court et à moyen et à long
terme et si je reprends les propos de de
Monique Lubin qui les reprend aussi au
président de la République si cette
réforme est la mère des retraites
qu'elle nécessite aussi qu'il y ait un
peu de pédagogie qui soit faite qu'elle
nécessite nécessairement qu'on
s'inscrive dans le dans le cours dans le
moyen et dans le long terme comment
expliquer vous le caractère incomplet
des informations qui vont être
transmises et qui ne nous permettent pas
à nous parlementaires de faire preuve de
pédagogie de nous inscrire dans le moyen
de le long terme
monsieur le président
j'ai toujours plaisir monsieur le
sénateur à venir parmi vous retrouvez
même avec des informations lacunaires et
un mandat réduit
on peut quand même dire un certain
nombre de choses et avoir un sens de
débat il y en a d'autres que je vais pas
pouvoir
entreprendre par exemple le slogan plus
de pédagogie moins démagogie pas pouvoir
être assez consensuel parmi vous je ne
peux pas en revanche pas tout à fait
développer la réponse la question qui
déposée j'ai pas répondu sur la mer des
réformes mais moi je vais quand même
tenter de percer la première c'est que
merder réformes
mais cette réforme ne suffira pas à
équilibrer nos finances publiques
on le sait et deuxièmement
si c'est une mère elle aura les enfants
parce que ce ne sera pas la dernière
réforme question 2 de choses que nous
savons puisque même dans les
calculs qui sont rendus publics on sait
qu'au-delà de 2030
il y aura quand même d'autres exercices
à reprendre je ferme cette parenthèse il
y a deux questions auxquelles trois
questions auxquelles je peux vous
répondre la première c'est sur la
question du temps de travail et je vais
livrer deux réflexions la première c'est
que nous savons quand même que la durée
de travail est un facteur de croissance
est évident le travail du capital
l'innovation sont des facteurs de
croissance mais
ayant dit ça il est évident aussi que
l'arbitrage entre temps de travail tant
de loisirs temps de la vie et
profondément un choix politique que
chacun d'entre nous peut aborder par
certains regards la deuxième chose c'est
que s'agissant d'une réforme des
retraites on sait bien que si on
considère c'est une prémisse qui peut
être discutée mais la Cour est
clairement du côté de la nécessité d'une
réforme parce que nous pensons que le
système tel qu'il est pas finançable
si on a un besoin de financement
les ressources vous les connaissez c'est
l'augmentation des cotisations
c'est la dégradation des pensions ou
c'est l'augmentation de la durée de
travail alors après la forme est-ce que
c'est l'âge légal est-ce que c'est pas
du tout mon rayon mais si je me pose sur
un point de vue économique et financier
il y a ces trois leviers et nous nous
sommes prononcés à plusieurs reprises en
disant que en effet il fallait tout de
même que ce soit le temps de travail sur
la durée de la vie qui soit un peu plus
long ce qui est aussi un facteur
macroéconomique encore une fois je le
dis sans me prononcer en quoi que ce
soit sur les modalités de la réforme
c'est vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en lien avec le gouvernement
les partenaires sociaux c'est ça la
démocratie nous sommes une institution
experte et qui délivre des avis
importants mais nous ne sommes pas à
votre place j'ai trop fait de politique
je respecte trop le politique pour
vouloir lui donner la moindre le
soi-même si j'ai quelques mémoires en
effet monsieur le sénateur puisqu'en
2001 il se trouve qu'au moment du
passage à l'euro j'étais ministre des
états européennes ça ne me rajeunit pas
je l'étais même déjà depuis un certain
nombre d'années j'avais été jeune
ministre il est vrai et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque on parlait souvenons-nous de
l'Allemagne comme de l'homme malade de
l'Europe étant un peu changé si on
regarde en effet les performances de
notre commerce extérieur les
performances de votre industrie les
performances de nos finances publiques
il y a quand même je crois que quelques
sujets de réflexion collectif puisque
depuis lors on a quand même essayé pas
mal de formes politiques dans notre pays
on a changé assez souvent président de
formation dominante etc et on a une
certaine continuité donc encore une fois
tu crois que les interrogations sur nos
finances publiques elles sont pour
maintenant sur notre industrie également
mais au-delà de cette remarque très
générale je voudrais faire plus
particulière sur la sur la dette
dans une autre vie aussi j'ai été mise
et finances c'était une époque où
c'était en pleine crise financière et
Chris grecque et la dette publique la
charge de la dette est-elle le deuxième
budget de l'État je ne souhaite pas à
mon pire ennemi de venir miserance dans
ces conditions parce que vous n'avez pas
la moindre marge de manœuvre pour faire
quoi que ce soit or
nous en approchons le budget de la
défense c'est 41 milliards d'euros
hors pension avec les pensions c'est 50
milliards d'euros il va sans doute être
évalué par la loi de programmation
militaire mais il faut trouver les
moyens de la financer cette loi de
programmation militaire
et la charge de la dette j'ai dit
pourrait atteindre 44 milliards d'euros
le jour où vous avez quand même la
charge de la dette comme le deuxième
budget de l'État
c'est vraiment c'est la dépense publique
c'est la plus stupide la plus inerte la
plus introductive la plus inefficace la
plus absurde c'est-à-dire que chaque
euro vous allez consacrer à rembourser
la dette que nous allons rembourser
collectivement rembourser la dette est
un euro en moins pour les préférences de
chacun pour
du travail pour de la justice pour de la
sécurité pour de l'écologie pour de
l'éducation pour de la recherche
vraiment je crois que c'est un sujet
certains semblent avoir une préférence
pour la dette ça n'a pas de sens
non la dette est vraiment la dépense
publique qui stérilise tout et nous
entrons car nous sommes sortis de la
période des taux d'intérêt négatif dans
une période où
la charge de la dette augmente elle
augmente à la fois on le sait du fait du
poids des obligations à l'excès
inflation et pour l'instant vous avez
encore une inflexion
d'intérêt dont nous savons qu'elle ne va
pas s'arrêter madame Lagarde il y a
encore deux jours à expliquer que quand
tu la situation de l'inflation en Europe
il y aurait des hausses de taux
d'intérêt substantiels je la cite c'est
une réflexion quand même que nous devons
vraiment je crois avoir doux encore une
fois la nécessité en effet de disposer
d'une loi de programmation finance
publique et je regarde tout à fait
d'accord avec vous monsieur le sénateur
c'est une question juridique je soulève
les obstacles juridiques parce qu'à un
moment donné ça coince quand même c'est
à dire que on ne pense pas que c'est une
simple formalité qu'on peut vivre sans
non non un moment donné on est rattrapé
par la patrouille je sais pas quand je
sais pas comment mais je vois quand même
arriver un vrai sujet mais
l'ayant dit vous avez raison sur le fait
que c'était aussi un sujet politique et
démocratique qu'il faut éclairer nos
concitoyens aussi sur la structure des
dépenses et des recettes que la lol
d'ailleurs en fait maintenant
l'obligation dans sa nouvelle formule
davantage au gouvernement bon c'est
aussi un des rôles de la Cour des
comptes je sors de mon rôle le président
aujourd'hui que de contribuer par ses
rapports à porter un certain nombre
d'éclairage et on trouve dans nos
travaux aussi un certain nombre de ta
formation c'est notre fierté que de les
délivrer c'est notre plaisir et
messieurs les sénateurs quand vous nous
le demandez en l'occurrence comme vous
me le demandez puisque je suis le
porte-parole de cette institution en
quelque sorte que nous avons présenté
ces travaux ce que je referais bien
volontiers soit comme président de au
Conseil des finances publiques soit
comme président de Premier président de
la Cour des comptes
merci monsieur le Président et je vous
dis à bientôt alors